make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with dark knight's metal but this one
gets a little crazy and so i think that
before we kick this off what we need to
do is have a discussion about the
overvoid now in reality it would
probably be hoover since we are comics
explained it would probably behoove us
to essentially take
everything that's happened with regards
to dark knight's metal and these these
additions and
creations in relation to like how the
multiverse works and all that kind of
stuff to kind of consolidate all of that
into a singular video and it makes sense
of
everything that's happened but for what
we're gonna do in this video we're gonna
have a conversation about the overvoid
right because the overvoid plays a role
in all of this actually plays a huge
role in all of this
so the waze works in dc comics right
leaving out like the dark multiverse and
all that kind of stuff the way this
works in dc comics is that you have like
a singular universe
and dc uses numerical designations for
their universes but unlike marvel where
it's arbitrarily established dc does it
in order
right so you have earth zero then you
have earth one then you have earth two
you have earth three right that's kind
of how their whole thing goes and works
forward from there
something like earth zero or earth prime
that's where you read most of these dc
comics
ever since the new 52. now outside of
these individual universes you have of
course the multiverse and you guys know
this stuff right you guys have the
multiverse a collection of universes
the presence is basically the one who
created the multiverse
right that's kind of been established
over the years in different comics
crisis undefeated earth the subsequent
stories that we've seen like doomsday
clock which referenced
crisis on infinite earth and solidified
the creation of the multiverse by the
hand of the presence
in the the dc rebirth landscape right so
we know it's still in continuity
but the big question to ask here is if
the presence created the multiverse
who created the presence so that's where
the omniverse comes into play and we've
talked about this in marvel comics right
the omniverse
is basically all the multiverses that
exist so like the multiverse from marvel
comics and the multiverse from like
spawn and like the like if it if it
exists out there in reality
it's part of the omniverse right it's
just the omniverse encompasses
everything that currently exists that we
are currently aware of right so
our universe and assuming that we as
human beings here in the real world are
part of a multiverse and includes our
multiverse as well
and so the over void was kind of like
this introduction by grant morrison that
was designed to take the place of just
saying like all people in creation right
now by and large grant morrison did it
in relation to dc comics but if you look
at the nature of grant morrison it kind
of expands beyond dc comics and so what
we can kind of do is we can we can look
at like the real world here and we can
say like in the 1930s you had like
malcolm wheeler nicholson and you had
harry donovan
and you had max gaines and you had
robert canager and you had gardner fox
and these were the people
who basically created dc comics as we
know it today and then in the 1930s you
also had like jack kirby
and you had joe simon they were the ones
who created people like captain america
and that over the years different
writers have contributed to characters
in different ways right bob kane bill
finger created batman it was just kind
of the way these things work and so when
grant morrison created the overvoid in
in final crisis instead of saying like
once upon a time there was gardner fox
and max gaines and robert canager and
harry donnefeld and malcolm wheeler
nicholson and gardner fox and stan lee
and jack kirby and joe simon instead of
like
running off all these names he was just
like in the beginning there was the
overvoid and that's why you basically
have this kind of this this depiction in
the sense that the overvoid did not
initially become aware of the fact that
the dc multiverse existed
because if you apply this kind of meta
textual concept to it it was basically
grant morrison saying before these guys
created dc comics and marvel comics they
had lives they had wives and they had
kids and they had
you know friends and family and they
were going to school and all that kind
of stuff right and it wasn't until later
on in their life that they decided to
start creating comic books and that's
when they became aware of the existence
of things right so
it's super meta textual and it can be
difficult to wrap your head around right
there's no there's no denying that like
it could be difficult to wrap your head
around but that's kind of how all this
this whole
overvoid thing works and so the idea and
the reason why this matters is because
as we get into this of course we've had
metron who's been dead for quite some
time
in dc comics right he's been dead for a
while i think ever since the events of
darkseid war but
with the batman who laughs basically
achieving the full totality of dr
manhattan's powers
and becoming this just crazy powerful
multiversal source of energy
the first thing he does is challenge
perpetua because perpetua seems to more
or less be equal to himself in power
and these two beings are fighting quite
literally for the fate of the multiverse
if you guys are a little confused you
know a little confused in terms of like
the the level of power we're talking
about here to put this into context this
was like when the spectre and the
anti-monitor fought during crisis on
infinitives right it was their fight
that destroyed what was left of the
multiverse right it was just them
fighting that laid waste to basically
everything
but you're basically talking about two
insanely powerful beings here but the
reason why this matters is because
while all this has been happening dark
knight's metal and the and
you know the batman who laughs gaining
all his power and so on and so forth the
overvoid
has been watching and the overvoid is
actually curious and so what the
overvoid does
is it basically sends an emissary into
the main dc universe right into
into this particular place right here i
guess we can kind of call it the
multiverse if we want to but basically
this being
shows up here it's kind of a chronicler
of sorts and it's curious
right it's curious what's going on here
and so what it ends up doing is
basically teleporting to the hellscape
right which is premium
previously themaskira and it comes
across the joker the first person it
meets and it's like are you the one who
drew me here
right are you the one whose presence
drew me to this place and then he
immediately kind of picks up and
says no you're just the joker right like
if anything you're a nuisance on your
earth but aside from that you're wildly
insignificant right you don't really
matter in the greater scheme of things
and then he basically ends up moving to
the next cell and that's when he comes
across
roger hayden the psycho pirate and the
reason why he grabs a psycho pirate is
because remember where you've had events
like crisis on infinite earth and zero
hour crisis in time an
infinite crisis and final crisis one of
the things we've kind of reiterated here
is that crisis on infinite earth
destroyed the multiverse infinite crisis
brought the multiverse back
and final crisis made the heroes aware
of it but after each one of these major
crisis events you would usually see some
kind of reboot right in the sense that
the heroes
didn't remember anything that was going
on before those crisis events so really
before
crisis on infinite earth infinite crisis
and final crisis weren't really as
grandiose in scale as the original
crisis of it that's why i say dc's only
ever rebooted twice
the original crisis event and the new 52
right but even when we go into new 52
most people don't remember anything
before the new 52 it's why barry allen
initially forgot who wally west was it's
why when you had
pre new 52 superman who showed up in the
new 52 universe people didn't initially
know who he was and then you had the
whole
superman reborn story arc where
basically him and the new 52 version
merged and then you got like the
original superman as we know him right
that kind of a thing it was
kind of a wonky story but the long and
short of this is that psychopirate
does remember all of that right psycho
pirate remembers life remembers how
things work
before the events of crisis on
infinitives and he remembers how things
were
after that and he remembers everything
before the events of flashpoint and he
knows everything that's been going on
since right so he's the only true source
of knowledge insofar as the entire
timeline
before during and after the crisis that
dc's had
and so one of the things this guy
basically says here is that he's he's
known as chronicler right that's
basically his name right his name is
chronicler and that he
has what's called the codex omniversa
and that he is a person
that's sent into a universe to chronicle
the universe document why it is that
it's dying and then
leave and that's basically it that's his
whole purpose he's more or less just
like a librarian right just a
chronicler and so as he goes through
here and as he looks into the mind of of
psychopirate he basically recalls
everything right like the original
justice society of america
before the events of crisis on offenders
the heroes as they existed
after and then everything that came
after the event of flashpoint right new
52 and so when he's looking at that like
it immediately
strikes him as interesting because he's
kind of like this multiverse is
remarkable right it's not like most
multiverses that i've seen that have
been destroyed where there aren't really
any superheroes there right where it's
basically just kind of mundane this is a
little strange to me and so from there
like it kind of piques his interest
you know and he's like let's see what
else is here the funny thing about it is
that when he explains himself
and says like i'm always sent into a
multiverse when the multiverse is about
to die it kind of strikes psycho pirate
like wait a minute like this is the end
right this is how it ends the funny
thing about this too
is psycho pirate tries to use his medusa
mask on chronicler it doesn't work right
and
we'll find out more about why it doesn't
work here in a minute i mean he kind of
offers an explanation and saying that
he's incapable of feeling for the dead
and so basically it's kind of him saying
like this multiverse is going to die and
so because you're a dead man i don't
really feel anything for you but the
reason why the medusa mask doesn't work
is actually a little deeper than that
right well not really deeper but it's a
little different than that and so from
there he ends up teleporting to another
location and is immediately met by like
all these different robots right these
these kind of you know drones and so on
and he wipes them out with the wave of
his hand
and they're all totally destroyed which
proves to be a big deal because these
are the forces of real docs right the
son of brainiac so you're talking about
the son of like a 12th level
intelligence who created these drones
that would be a challenge for someone
like superman right let alone an
army of them and so this guy's power is
pretty high up there but as he starts
talking to vril docks the funny thing
about this is that real doc says he's
been sending signals into the greater
omniverse to basically find a way to
escape this multiverse before his
inevitable death right so girl docs
knows the multiverse is going to die
right here like he knows this is this is
going to happen that everything
is going to end and that's why i say
dark knight's medal is in effect a
crisis event it's leading to the death
of the multiverse and that's usually
what a crisis means
it means like they're going to reboot or
something along those lines right it's
kind of become part and parcel with dc
nomenclature ever since the original
crisis event right it's just kind of
what it means now the funny thing about
this is that real docs had registered
an incursion from the omnibus basically
meaning like he registered this guy
arriving right you know chronicler
arriving from the omniverse and that's
why he kind of knew it was only a matter
of time before the chronicler came here
and so what he does is actually pitch
him a deal and he says here's what i'll
do
if you take me out of this multiverse
and and take me to a better multiverse
it'll actually survive then i will give
you
all the recorded history that's inside
the databanks that belong to my father
brainiac right every world he ever
recorded across
all of his existence across the
multiverse right here i'll give you all
that stuff
and so the responsive chronicler is well
i mean i do appreciate you giving me all
that but i'm not authorized to make
deals with dead men basically saying i'm
not going to take you to a new
multiverse and instead what he actually
ends up doing is
basically absorbing that knowledge from
real docs and then looking around right
because real docs offers him an
explanation on like everything outside
of earth the psycho pirate never really
functioned outside of earth right he was
never part of the green lantern corps
or part of like the new gods or anything
along those lines and so you actually
end up having him
end up having drill docks offering that
kind of explanation right showing him
that information and the crazy thing is
chronicler looks at this and says
there's
so much power in this universe how could
you let it get to this point like how
could you let your your multiverse get
to this point where it's on the verge of
collapse then it doesn't make any sense
right you have enough power to overthrow
virtually any threat you face
how could you let it get to this point
now wherever docs initially tries to
take over
um take over the chronicler and then
says like i intend to use your power to
leave this place the chroniclers
response is do you really want to see
what lies beyond your reality do you
really want to see the sorts of
multiverses i've recorded
as they've died and that's when he shows
in the codex omniversa now we don't
necessarily see what's in the codex
omniversa but we're given an explanation
of what is in there and what the
chronicle basically tells us is that
like
among the various multiverses that he's
seen this one is the only one that
really has the kind of power
that's being displayed here that within
this multiverse that exists here that
this one's unique
now if i'm also a betting man assuming
the chronicler has visited like the
marvel multiverse it's kind of dc comics
basically saying
our multiverse is better right that's
kind of what it is
that's kind of what they're saying here
but the overall point is that there is
nothing else out there
right and this kind of comes by way of
the response of real docs when the
chronicler leaps right when the
chronicler is like i require more
knowledge your knowledge is far too
limited right i require a better
understanding of this whole universe
that's out there and
basically ends up taking off but the
response of real docs is no there has to
be something better out there right
there has to be something better than
this place but the response of the
chronicler is
no you didn't cherish what you had right
your multiverse is coming to an end
and it sucks because your multiverse was
so special and so like so it's kind of
like if i took you to a different
multiverse it wouldn't be nearly as good
as this one and in fact it would
probably suck it would be worse right so
i'd be taking you to a worse place which
is not going to happen
and so what he ends up doing is
traveling to the moon right teleporting
to the moon in the midst of this massive
battle
right between perpetua and and the the
batman who laughs right the dr manhattan
who last counted character and he
actually ends up picking up the skull
of metron and then basically says like i
need clarity from one who has seen this
universe as i'm seeing it now
an observer so basically he wants to
better understand this universe as it
exists in the moment and
metron is the only one who can do that
right he's the only one who surveyed the
entirety of the universe and gathered as
much information as he possibly can
it's the nature of metron right it's
what he does and so what he does here is
basically
resurrect this guy from the dead and so
what this gives us is this indication
that chronicler is an almost nine
omnipotent character this guy
is huge in terms of power the other part
of this is we get some massive
explanations and exposition
insofar as how all this kind of
hierarchy stands right the presence
all that kind of stuff and so when
metron wakes up it's basically like he's
been dead all this time right so he
doesn't really know
anything about about dark knight's medal
the batman who laughs any of that stuff
he's been dead this whole time and so
it's kind of like when chronicler kind
of explains it all to him he's just sort
of like
wow okay so perpetua apparently was
locked in the source wall she was the
creator of this multiverse as it exists
that's kind of crazy right she was
defeated she was locked inside the
source wall the whole multiverse was
recreated by her
sons right and then she manipulated the
anti-monitor into becoming the villain
that he was which led to the second
crisis right so crisis on infinite earth
right it led to that event and then
she's kind of just been manipulating
things ever since so she could
eventually escape the source wall and
then usurp control of the multiverse
right so damn this is kind of crazy and
then the batman who laughs is a version
of batman from the dark multiverse and
then he ended up getting the power of dr
manhattan who came here from a different
universe and then like
it's just it's it's he basically gets
the full explanation of everything
that's been going on here and the idea
is that
as he talks to the chronicler the
chronicler is saying things like i wish
to understand
why things are the way they are how did
your multiverse get to this point and
the response of metron here is i'm a
passive observer i just watch everything
from a macro scale and that's when he
kind of picks up on the fact that the
function of the chronicler is to simply
observe but what he wants to do is
actually fix
things right it's to fix this multiverse
and make it right the way that it's
supposed to be so when he says yes right
when the chronicler is more or less like
yes
then at the end of the day metron is
like okay it's kind of difficult to
explain right but what he basically
establishes here is that metron himself
is part of the new gods and the new gods
represent absolute good versus absolute
evil or seemingly absolute good versus
absolute evil the nature of these
characters and the nature of this is
almost kind of meta textual
that you have heroes who exist in this
universe and within the multiverse
itself and the idea is that the heroes
are effectively written by
you know dc writers represented by the
overvoid in such a way to where they
will always find a way to overcome
it's why every villain doesn't kill
superman it's why the joker doesn't kill
batman
every single time they fight right it's
why superman hasn't died yet well i
guess he kind of did but he ended up
coming back it's why the superheroes
basically always win is because it's the
overvoid representing
dc comics writers that engineer ways by
which the heroes will always come out on
top and that's why he says things like
the omni vs finite because while the
omniverse does represent all things that
currently exist
then there are only so many things that
we as human beings have created if you
go through and you say like
if you were to catalog a list of
everything that that every human being
has created insofar as like a story that
exists out there then sure there'd be a
lot
right there be millions and millions and
millions and millions of stories but
they stop at a certain number right they
don't go on forever we don't look around
and say there are an infinite number of
stories that we as human beings have
created with regards to things like
spawn or like the twilight zone or
the outer limits tv show or something
like that there's only so many of these
things that we've created over the years
right over our existence now that number
will continue to grow the longer the
humanity exists but
at the moment right now there's only
only a finite number there but the
potential
is limitless the potential of what we as
people can create
is limitless and so the idea of what
what metron says here is that because of
the fact that everything that exists
within the omniverse so like marvel
comics dc comics all that kind of stuff
that all exists
because of the fact that people created
it and so even if dc were to just close
up shop right now right is really what
metron saying even if this multiverse
were to die and never be reborn right so
like dc finishes dark nights metal and
says okay guys the book is shut they
fire everybody and they say we're no
longer making comic books
then like the memories of everything
that's happened here will continue to
live on right the omniverse representing
scott snyder and jeff johns and all
these people who are currently
contributing to or have contributed to
dc comics and are still alive and even
us
as the reader we will all remember this
even if we can never read a dc comic
again after this we'll all say like hey
remember that story with superman
that's how those things will live on and
so that's that's kind of it's
exceedingly meta textual here but the
chronicler still doesn't quite grasp it
and so the way this ends is that metron
says fun then it's easier to show you
than it is to tell you
and so what he basically ends up doing
is kind of blasting him with the full
totality of what it means to truly
understand the codex omniversa he
basically gives him
true knowledge like a like an almost
beyond multiversal and omniversal cosmic
awareness
seemingly what he does is kind of
introduce the chronicler to
us basically tell us like about the real
world that kind of seems to be what
happens whether or not that's actually
the case i don't really know right it's
just
i'm just kind of suspecting here but
with that being said guys uh we're going
to bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you